you were talking about how wealth goes
away after a few generations and how you
actually had a team that was studying
Vanderbilt and a bunch of other
generationally wealthy people to make
sure that this doesn't happen with your
family what did you find out from these
studies I interviewed this guy his job
is to deal with families that are worth
their $100 million and higher to make
sure their kids turn out well that's his
job and he's in Seattle why is that
important Amazon Microsoft a lot of
billionaires lot of Hector Millionaires
and I said what was the common theme you
realized when you got there to help the
families what was it Patrick 99% of the
time it's too late they call me once
their kid is already a drug addict they
call me once their kid is already a
alcoholic they call me after they
already got their kids three
Lamborghinis they already flying all
over the place on a private jet it's
done there's nothing you can do about it
at that time